engin agricole isolée camion de chantier
cube non éclairé leur réservoir imposant
des proies faciles pour les siphonneurs
mal intentionnés cette année dans
l'yonne ce sont 110 vols enregistrés
pour plus de 33 mille litres de
carburant on s'est fait voler du
carburant dans nos engins de travaux
publics sur une carrière qu'on exploite
point un client on se fait voler entre
600 et 800 litres ici fun directement
les réservoirs qui met ça dans des
bidons et ils repartent avec leur
véhicule
de toute façon c'est les sites sont pas
sécurisés on n'est pas du tout assuré
pour ce genre de vol
donc c'est vraiment de la perte osseuse
ou les entreprises de transport et des
exploitations agricoles sont les plus
touchés par ces vols avec l' approche de
l'hiver et l'augmentation des prix du
fioul et du gaz oil ces axes multiplie
les délinquants opère deux nuls et
semble particulièrement organisé 2008 à
peu près en quatre fois et donc du coup
comment ça se passe vous avez une idée
de comment ils s'y prennent
ben il force là il force la porte qui
rentre pis cerd
les forces de l'ordre appelle donc à la
vigilance s'équiper pour dissuader de
fonctionner on a eu quand même une
grosse proportion d'agriculteurs et de
professionnels du transport qui sont qui
sont touchés et localisation
géographique des faits c'est quand même
bien le long de l'autoroute
on recommande également un système qui
marche très très bien qui est celui de
la caméra gibier qui est donc utilisé
dans le domaine de la chasse ces caméras
gibier actuellement sont très
performantes et vous permettre d'avoir
une alerte immédiate
donc sur votre smartphone vous avez la
photo immédiatement de fait qu'ils sont
en train de se dérouler les
professionnels ne sont pas les seules
victimes avions si seulement 15% des
délits concerne les particuliers les
gendarmes s'interrogent sur une
éventuelle accélération du phénomène
avec l'envolée des prix à la pompe le
jeune à